this is again our camera way down in the
southeast on top of black mountain in
henderson and before the sun comes up it
still stays a black and white picture
now throughout the last couple of hours
we have seen streaks of rain and right
in front of this camera
one round is about to exit stage right
but there's definitely more where this
came from in fact now this is our future
cast that is should give you an idea
that we're talking about a projection
not actual radar but this is a computer
projection so in the next 45 minutes
there will be one more round here as we
push one out then in the next couple of
hours by 8 a.m still definitely some
rain going on and snow up at mount
charleston possibly down in the
mountains edge area but by nine o'clock
it's going to be the east side and maybe
the far far north as you get towards
mount charleston then by 10 o'clock this
round will be pretty much over but
there's a lot more going on we'll check
neighborhood temperatures for you
dropping into the 40s and i believe a
lot of these numbers are going to begin
to drop before the sun tries to come up
and get things turned around but when
the storm clouds clear out by the way
about a tenth of an inch so it was a
nice steady little pitter patter
hopefully it didn't interrupt your
travels that joe is going to update the
roads here in just a second to nevada
and beyond definitely more snow for the
reno area even up in ely you're at 27. a
mix of snow and some rain showers for
caliente and mostly snow in the high
revelations outside of cedar
sandy valley you're at 50 same with over
the hump in corrupt
we keep trying for 60. we're going to
try it one more time today we believe
the sun will come out on your christmas
eve afternoon if we hit 60 that'll put
us above normal once this system tracks
out of here though there's plenty more
where that came from we'll talk about
that in the eight day forecast before
that just quickly though for your family
and friends on christmas eve snow
showers from the northern rockies all
the way down to new mexico some snow
across the u.s canadian border now for
the eastern third of the country it's
actually been a fairly quiet one so far
so it should be nice ride for santa okay
so showers around today clearing out
mostly sunny for christmas day but later
on tomorrow night the next round comes
in that rolls out of here on sunday then
another round coming in on monday and
high temperatures plummet we may see
highs only in the 40s very very windy on
wednesday and getting ready to say
goodbye to 2021 with some real cool
temperatures